yarm safinaz cachaca shonda's
you
my name is Rachel big and I'm a
community manager at Deutsche Welle and
have zero tolerance for hate speech if
it's allowed on the Internet at some
point it will become part of real life
too so I think no hate speech is a
strong message and I support it to see
it on a daily basis to see how much
hatred is out there is actually quite
disturbing sometimes if someone comes in
and trolls our page again and again and
we've warned him more than three times
then we're going to take the opportunity
to ban his account of course we don't do
it lightheartedly but I think it's one
of the strongest methods we have to give
those people are warning that we do not
accept hate speech on our pages I think
my worst day so far at work regarding
hate speech was when island Cody died
and his dead body was found on the beach
in Turkey and to blame him for his death
and to make fun of him and to say that
he deserved it i think it's it's really
really hard especially when you're
working here as a mom and i think one of
the most impressive things was actually
a troll coming out and saying i am a
troll I usually write a lot of racist
and abusive comments on your page but
this picture even shook me that I'm a
human being I have feelings and I feel
pity for this little boy personally of
course I would wish that hate speech
would stop that people would stop using
abusive language or racist opposed to
attack people but living in a world as
it is I think that is not possible there
will always be people who will be racist
and sexist and xenophobic
you